i just saw you pulling anthony davis
aside you got in his ear for quite some
time what were you telling him
[Applause]
in-house i'll stick with the stuff that
was out of house
pretty good night for you 33 points and
more importantly you guys are 2-0
ahead in this finals how do you feel
about the way you guys took control of
this game even when miami tried to make
a little run there in the third
it's a great team that we playing and uh
we understand that
we understand they put you in some
really tough positions offensively well
when they're offensive we're on defense
beating our switch attacks
doing a good job of slipping out we over
help a couple times they do a good job
of kicking out spraying out to their
shooters
i'm looking forward to watching the film
once again seeing ways we can be better
um because we can be and uh so i'm
looking forward to that
i mentioned a.d dwyane wade said tonight
he thinks anthony
is the best fit for you as a teammate
you've ever had what do you think of
that assessment
oh what's the compliment to a.d um
he's a big time player he understands
the
the position that he's in he understands
how much our team needs him and he comes
through
doesn't say much but we know that uh
he's very determined to
go out and only not only do what he
needs to do individually
but for the betterment of the team more
importantly tonight you passed magic
johnson
sixth all-time in finals games played
this was your 51st
nba finals game i joked to you the other
day that for the past decade save one
year it's been the lebron james
invitational
does it ever get old or does it feel
special every time no it never gets old
being on the stage
that's what i work my tail off for to be
able to play into
june october um and
i'm i'm honored to be able to be with
such a great uh franchise with great
teammates great coaching staff and a
great fan base
to be able to represent the western
conference so it will never get old to
me i just try to
take full advantage of it while i can
and you're wearing a very special jersey
tonight representing that franchise
those are the black mambas nick skin
jerseys you guys are undefeated in those
unis
anthony told me he said we just feel
like we can't lose there's pressure
extra pressure we cannot lose in these
do you feel the same way
um well it's always special to be able
to represent someone that meant so much
not only to the game but obviously to
the lakers organization for 20-plus
years
and for us to honor him being on the
floor
um this is what it's all about and uh
you know
we're thinking about uh the bryant
family vanessa and them daughters
um they're with us we're with you guys
uh we love you guys and hopefully
we make you know we're making them proud
by wearing these uniforms tonight and
throughout the course of the postseason
thank you so much lebron lately